[Music]
over the past 4 and A2 years we have
made hundreds of videos here on Journey
to the microcosmos and in that time we
have seen some Stars rise to the top to
become the true celebrities of the
microcosmos so this year we've taken
some of our most popular microscopic
friends and put together a 2024 calendar
featuring highlights from some of your
favorite microcosmos episodes we've got
your tardigrades your rotifers your
amoeba and Hydra but we've also got what
I think might be my favorite the long
necked lacr Maria the sea monkeys with
their dark past and a couple of
discoveries that James was shocked to
come across like the spoom and the
legendre each page features a little
blurb explaining what you're looking at
and a fantastic photo that showcases our
master of microscopes James Weiss's work
as a microscopist we love getting to
make this show each and every week and
we are continually Blown Away by the
support you all have shown for it so if
you'd like to bring the microcosmos home
with 12 dazzling photos to show off on
your wall pick up your 2024 Journey to
the microcosmos calendar over at
microcosmos dosto and if you'd like to
grab some other calendars from our
sibling channels eons bizarre beasts and
sow you can do so at complexly
calendars.com all those links of course
are in the
description